[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Thomas ménager bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec NCI pour votre invitation
député du Loiret porte-parole du groupe
rassemblement nationale à l'Assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Julien cuyer de la voie
du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour Orian
bonjour monsieur ménager on va revenir
sur l'information de cette nuit et le
parti d'extrême droite de gertvilders
qui a remporté les législatives au
Pays-Bas une victoire saluée
immédiatement par Marine Le Pen l'espoir
du changement reste vif en Europe
a-t-elle tweeté est-ce que vous ne
faites pas un peu trop de triomphalisme
Thomas non on félicite nos alliés au
Pays-Bas c'est une bonne nouvelle ils
ont doublé je crois le nombre d'élus ils
sont à 35 élus ils étaient à 17 au
auparavant ça augure aussi peut-être les
élections européennes 9 juin prochain où
nous nous appelons au-delà des
différences qu'on peut avoir sur les
questions de politique intérieure nous
sommes n'avons pas le même programme en
politique intérieure que nos alliés
européens mais nous partageons une
vision commune d'une Union européenne
qui n'est pas celle-ci qui une une
Europe des nations des nations
souveraines et nous sommes tous d'accord
pour que chacun retrouve sa liberté sa
souveraineté et donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle g Wilders Gard wildilders
justement en parlant d'Europe lui il
promet un référendum pour la sortie des
des Pays-Bas est-ce que ça vous inspire
non nous nous avons une ligne qui est
que la France c'est un grand pays et
contributeur net à l'Union européenne
est en capacité d'aller changer l'Union
européenne de l'intérieur de faire en
sorte que nous revenions peut-être aux
prémises de l'Union européenne
c'est-à-dire d'avoir une Europe des
nations des nations souveraines une
Europe des projets on se rend compte que
depuis des années on a bradé notre
souveraineté que ça marche pas que sur
un grand nombre de sujets en matière
d'immigration en matière d'écologie
punitive il faut que chaque pays
retrouve sa liberté donc nous nous
souhaitons pas le frexit mais vous t pas
totalement sur la même ligne mais je
vous dis nous sommes d'accord dans nos
désaccords c'est nous sommes d'accord
ord pour que les Néerlandais s'ils
souhaitent puissent s'exprimer dans tous
les cas nous sommes toujours d'accord
pour qu'il y ait la souveraineté
populaire et la capacité à aller aux
urnes pour décider de rester ou non au
sein de l'Union européenne mais nous
nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui la
France qui est un grand pays peut
changer l'Union européenne sauf que G
wildilders il n'est pas sûr d'être
Premier ministre puisque il va avoir des
difficultés à trouver des alliés et à
trouver une majorité est-ce que ça
montre pas qu'il y a encore des limites
après ça c'est la politique intérieure
néerlandaise j'ai compris qu'il y avait
un front commun contre contre notre
allié moi j'appelle quand même les
Néerlandais à respecter les yeuxs
c'estàd s'il a été placé en tête c'est
que une majorité de néerlandais
attendent qu'il qu'il dirige ce pays
mais après ça vous savez c'est de la
politique intérieure moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir ce qu'on
pourra faire avec nos alliés européens
le 9 juin prochain et avec j'espère la
liste de de Jordan Bardella en tête des
élections européennes pour changer
l'Union européenne et que chacun puisse
être libre un dirigeant néerlandais qui
qui compare le le corant à mcamp ça vous
dérange pas non mais après ça c'est
c'estes positions et et j'ai pas à
commenter lesc les prises de position de
cet allié voilà après ça ça reste un
allié mais c'est un allié nous sommes
d'accord pour retrouver notre liberté je
vous dis moi on est en capacité de dire
qu'on est en désaccord sur un certain
nombre de points je ferai pas cette
comparaison mais après c'est néerlandais
qui ont choisi et c'est un parti qui est
aujourd'hui en tête des élections au
Pays-Bas on va parler de ce qui se passe
en en Israël et de cet accord qui a été
trouvé entre Israël et le Hamas mais la
trêve qui a été repoussé et on l'apprend
ce matin repousser encore pour des
discussions de dernières minutes sur la
liste des otages à libérer est-ce que
néanmoins cet accord est un soulagement
pour vous mais moi j'ai surtout une
pensée pour pour les familles des otages
pour les proches c'est dire je pense que
l'attente est interminable et c'est vrai
qu'on on commande tout cela parfois en
oubliant mais mais c'est c'est la
difficulté de la vie politique que
derrière il y a des familles qui sont
venus à l'Assemblée nationale je crois
qu'il sont venus aussi au Sénat donc
dans tous les cas il faut que cet accord
aboutisse il restera encore énormément à
faire puisque je crois que c'est 50
alors il y a encore des négociations qui
sont en cours 50 sur 240 donc l'objectif
c'est que à terme il n'y ait plus aucun
otage détenu par le Hamas et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut bien
entendu soutenir la diplomatie française
notamment et tout ce qui pourra aller
vers la libération de ces personnes qui
sont détenues dans des conditions
atroces ont vécu des choses atroces le 7
octobre dernier à ce titre le le Qatar
reste un partenaire part particulier
pour négocier la libération des otages
mais est-ce qu'il faudra selon vous
s'interroger sur le rôle du Qatar et sa
place en France notamment vis-à-vis des
des conditions de d'installation des
entreprises qataries en France ce qui
est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est la libération des
otages donc il faut qu'on puisse
dialoguer avec l'ensemble des pays qui
ont une capacité à libérer notamment les
compatriotes nos compatriotes les
Français qui sont détenus mais
globalement tous les otages après bien
entendu on sait il y a un certain nombre
de liens entre la France et le Qatar qui
doivent être éclairci un certain nombre
d'avantages fiscaux nous nous avons
demandé à ce que les avantages fiscaux
qui aujourd'hui bénéficient au Catari so
soit supprimé nous l'avons déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale au moment du
projet de loi de finance donc il y a un
certain nombre de liens et de
financement de de de de lien un peu
trouble ou d'avantage qui existent
aujourd'hui en France au bénéfice des
cataries qui devrait être mis en cause
bien entendu Emmanuel Macron qui
pourrait retourner au Proche Orient dans
les prochains jours est-ce que la France
a un rôle à jouer dans la résolution de
ce conflit pour vous je pense et
j'espère que la diplomatie française la
France a une voie particulière on peut
s'inquiéter de l'affablissement
progressif de la France de la diplomatie
française donc bien bien entendu ce
déplacement tout dépend quelle sera la
ligne mais la France doit porter la
ligne qui est la ligne historique celle
des deux états celle d'une pacification
de de cette zone du monde c'est un sujet
difficile je pense que ceux qui
considèrent qu'il y a une solution
miracle après les décennies que nous
pourons connaître sur ce secteur serait
un peu présomptueux ce qui est certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous ce qui nous
inquiète c'est la ligne du président de
la République c'est on a du mal à la
comprendre je pense que en matière de
diplomatie il y a une vertu cardinale
qui est la constance et aujourd'hui en
depuis le 7 octobre on a eu d'un côté la
coalisation la Coalition pour le Hamas
on a eu d'un côté un appel au CC feu
avant d'avoir porté un soutien total aux
Israéliens donc on a un petit mal
comprenez pas aujourd'hui on comprend
pas la ligne du président de la
République je vous dis elle a changé
aujourd'hui il demande une solution à
deux états une trêve humanitaire qui
pourrait aboutir à un cesser le
feuraf il a demandé à un moment un
cesser le feu sans condition bien
entendu l'objectif à très long terme
c'est un cessé le feu mais avec
libération des otages avec éradication
du Hamas parce par qu'on ne peut pas
laisser une organisation terroriste
restructurée mais le président de la
République à tel point qu'il a même fait
plaisir à Monsieur Mélenchon parce que
quand il a appelé un cesser le feu sans
aucune condition il a été soutenu par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a du mal vraiment
à comprendre quelle est sa ligne et donc
c'est un peu un peu difficile à suivre
aujourd'hui on va parler de du Congrès
des mes qui se tient cette semaine
Emmanuel Macron qui recevait un millier
d'élus hier soir à l'Élysée Emmanuel
Macron qui a dit qu'il était conscient
de leur difficultés qu'il était à leur
écoute est-ce que pour vous il aurait dû
se rendre au Congrès des mères alors je
crois qu'en 2017 il y é était allé en en
prenant l'engagement d'y aller chaque
année au final d'année en année il y a
toujours une bonne excuse il préfère ce
format où on vient l'écouter au château
tel un monarque entouré de petits four
où en fait les maires n'ont même pas la
possibilité de l'interroger ou du moins
pas publiquement donc ça ça pose
question c'était assez j'aiécouté son
discours hier soir qui était diffusé
c'est que j'avais l'impression d'avoir
le discours d'un candidat j'étais assez
d'accord avec tout ce qui disait je me
disais mais incroyable je suis d'accord
avec Emmanuel Macron mais parce que fait
lui non on en est pas là parce que
malheureusement
le discours du candidat on peut on peut
le partager sur les difficultés des
maires mais derrière il est président de
la République depuis 7 ans on a toujours
les mêmes discours toujours les mêmes
marotes sur le statut de l'él local
pareil pendant le grand débat en 2019 on
nous avait dit on va avancer sur le
statut de l'él local c'est à un moment
Emmanuel Macron j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'a jamais compris qu'il n'était plus
candidat mais qu'il était président
qu'il devait gouverner qu'il devait
prendre des dispositions notamment pour
nos maères qui ne sont pas DUP parce que
un certain nombre aussi on boycotté ils
ont bien eu raison je pense cet
événement alors hier soir a parl je le
cite d'un système qui est cul par-dessus
tête et il s'est engagé à mener dans
l'année qui vient des centralisation
réelle et audacieuse c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais je vous dis je vous dis on
peut être d'accord c'est ce qu'attend en
partie les maires c'est notamment le
couple maire préfet il y a plein de
choses qui vont dans le bon sens dans ce
qu'il dit mais il lui reste plus que 2
ans et demi 3 ans il va falloir un
moment qu'il comprenne que c'est à lui
de bosser c'est bien de faire les
constats mais c'est pas un éditorialiste
c'est pas un journaliste c'est pas un
commentateur c'est le président de la
République française donc à un moment on
est d'accord mais je pense que les
maires ils en ont marre d'attendre il y
a une mission qui a été confiée à votre
collègue Eric vert est-ce que pour vous
c'est la bonne méthode va voir vous
savez de créer des missions de créer des
comités de de créer d'autres types de
manières de faire la la démocratie et et
et de faire vivre le débat politique
pourquoi pas mais aujourd'hui avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est toujours la même
chose c'estàd qu'en fait on va créer un
comité qui va rendre un rapport et on va
pas suivre le rapport donc à un moment
je pense que les maires ils lui ont dit
et ils savent ce qu'ils veulent et il
faut les écouter il y a eu un thème qui
a été particulièrement mis en valeur
cette année c'est évidemment les
agressions vis-à-vis des des élus alors
qui ont augmenté qui devrait augmenter
de 15 % en 2023 après une hausse de 32 %
l'an dernier la ministre des collecités
des collectivités territoriales
Dominique fort a annoncé le lancement
d'un numéro vert de soutien
psychologique après un plan en juillet
on annonce aussi que le gouvernement
pourrait soutenir une proposition de loi
sénatoriale pour durcir les les
sanctions pénales vis-à-vis des
agresseur est-ce que pour vous là aussi
c'est des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens alors de la même manière en fait
Emmanuel Macron je crois il y a 6 8 mois
a dit les numéros verts c'est ce qu'on
fait quand on ne sait pas quoi faire
d'autres faut arrêter avec les numéros
verts et on se rend compte que 6 mois
après qu'il a dit ça il lance un nouveau
numéro vert ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y a une vraie détresse auprès des
élus locaux qui n'en peuvent plus d'être
en première ligne d'être agressés et et
et ils font face en fait à la à la
réalité face à la violence à la montée
de la violence qu'on voit constat mais
qu'estce que qu'est-ce que vous vous P
fa auour'ui pe faire annonce alors on
peut peut-être aller vers un
durcissement des peines mais aujourd'hui
il faut qu'il y ait une la fin du
laxisme c'estàdire que ce qui arrive
pour les maires arrive pour tous les
Français donc à un moment il faut une
politique pénale très ferme il faut des
poursuites systématiques avec des
instructions données au parquet pour
qu'à chaque fois qu'un élu notamment
mais pour toutous les Français ça ne
tient pas que pour les élus il y ait des
poursuites qu'il y ait peut-être un
durcissement des peines pourquoi pas
mais que déjà les peines actuelles
soient appliquées qu'il y ait les moyens
nécessaires pour que aujourd'hui quand
il y a une attaque envers un élu il y
ait des poursuites moi j'ai des élus sur
mon territoire qui n'ont jamais vu
aboutir les plaintes qui ne voient rien
suivre c'estàd qu'en fait il y a des
discours mais dans les acte il faut
juste la fin de Laer la fin du laxisme
et quand on sait que Monsieur Dupont
morti était peut-être ministre habitant
il y a peut-être un changement aussi de
cap en la matière il y a aussi la
question des strates du nombre de
strates qui se pose et du nombre des
champs est-ce que pour vous il faut
supprimer des strates alors aujourd'hui
il y a eu il y a des débats parce que
c'est vrai que on ne sait plus les
compétences sont partagées un certain
nombre de compétences sont difficiles à
à à suivre il y avait la question de la
réforme territoriale la question de de
de de faire des évolutions aujourd'hui
c'était pareil on a connu le débat sous
Nicolas Sarkozi on a connu ce débat sur
Emmanuel Macron on parle le 4 mars d'un
congrès d'une révision constitutionnelle
mais aujourd'hui le président de la
République n'évoque pas de telles
évolutions on voit bien que aujourd'hui
il y a besoin de dans tous les cas de
redonner le pouvoir au maires qui sent
aujourd'hui bien qu'ondre par exemple
les les finances locales c'est une des
pistes de réforme il y a aujourd'hui un
problème qui l'autonomie financière
c'est-à-dire qu'avec la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation il y a besoin de se
reposer la question c'estàdire qu'ils
ont plus la main sur des leviers fiscaux
suffisants pour être maître et respecter
ce principe de libre administration ils
ont plus cette autonomie financière
minimale un congrès pardon je fais une
petite parenthèse Congrès le 4 mars
notamment sur la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG vous le voterz euh
vraisemblablement on va voir faut qu'il
y ait un vote dans les dans les mêmes
termes à titre personnel je le voterai
vous connaissez la position du
rassemblement nationale au en première
lecture nous avons été une majorité de
députés à voter pour mais nous avons une
liberté de vote non pas sur la question
de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse puisque le rassemblé sociale
défend l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais sur une question plus
technique plus juridique plus
constitutionnel de savoir s'il y a
nécessité à l'inscrire je considère que
euh il y avit peut-être d'autres
priorités parce qu'au aujourd'hui il y a
aucun parti représenté au Parlement
aucune personnalité qui remet en cause
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et c'est une bonne chose mais que il y a
d'autres choses aussi à faire s'il y a
une révision constitutionnelle les
Français attendent ce que nous nous
proposons je pense c'est l'inscription
du droit des étrangers la question du
référendum c'est une majorité pour une
majorité contre dans notre groupe en
première lecture mais attendez ça
dépendra le texte qui nous sera
définitivement proposé en fonction des
navettes nous avons été une majorité à
voté pour lors de on revient à ce qui
s'est passé hier soir parceque lors de
ce discours devant les maires Julien
Emmanuel Macron a dénoncé le terrible
assassinat du jeune Thomas on en parle
avec vous oui tout à fait puisqueil y a
eu plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
ont défilé hier en silence en hommage au
lycéen de 16 ans tué dimanche à coup de
couteau en marche d'un bal dans le
village de de Crépol alors ellisabeth B
s s'est exprimé également et appelé à la
dessence à la retenue je la cite
utiliser ce drame pour jouer sur les
peurs c'est manquer de dignité de
respect pour les victimes est-ce que
vous êtes senti viser au RN non mais ce
qui est certain c'est que le manque de
dignité c'est l'inaction c'estàd qu'à un
moment c'est facile d'attaquer ses
opposants qui parlent de fait réel d'une
montée de la violence de l'indélinquence
en ruralité notamment et je considère
queaujourd'hui c'est indigne de laés de
la première ministre si elle nous
attaque de parler de ce sujet d'apporter
des solutions
du moins c'est comme ça que vous l'avez
interprété donc on a considéré qu'on
était visé c'estàdire que elle s passer
on a fait la liaison parce que Marine Le
Pen a a réagi très rapidement en
évoquant une attaque organisée
maintenant je la cite encore he d'un
certain nombre de banlieux criminogènes
dans lesquels se trouvent des milices
armées qui opèrent des RADIAS alors
beaucoup de termes qui répondent encore
une fois à des à une situation qui est a
éclairé l'enquête est en cours
visiblement le le le l'auteur présumé
des coups de couteau il vient pas d'une
bandue criminogène en l'occurrence il
viendrait du du centre de de de Toulouse
est-ce qu'elle est pas allé trop vite en
besogne non mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y a plusieurs profils et
qu'il y en a certains qui viennent quand
même de certains quartiers euh'estce que
ça veut dire oui de qu par aujourd'hui
on sait très bien que c'est la
conséquence notamment de l'immigration
une immigration incontrôlée qui depuis
des années a par Immigration en fait
excusez-moi mais la la là encore
l'enquête le dira mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on a affaire à des à des
personnes étrangères non mais attendez
il y a deux choses ça peut être des
personnes qui sont nationalité
étrangères mais ça peut être des
personnes qui malheureusement du fait de
l'immigration incrôlé de l'absence
d'assimilation sont des
personnesimigration mais ils peuvent
être issus d'immigration depuis
plusieurs générations à partir deel à
partir de quel moment ils sont plus
considérés comme immigrés non mais ils
sont toujours dans tous les cas ils sont
français ils sont français mais
aujourd'hui qu dans un certain nombre de
quartiers dans un certain nombre de
quartiers monsieur dans un certain
nombre de quartiers où il y a des
défauts d'assimilation quand on a laissé
entrer des personnes sur notre sol sans
obliger à respecter nos uses et coutumes
nos valeurs les valeurs de la République
on en arrive à la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que
c'est la même chose que pour les émeutes
moi je l'ai vu à montargie sur mon
territoire dans le Loiré c'estàd qu'il y
a bien entendu des personnes qui sont
soit naturalisées ou qui sont immigrés
de la seconde génération ça fait c'était
leurs parents qui sont arrivés sur notre
sol mais qui face à l'absence de fermeté
de l'État face à l'absence de volonté
d'assimilation c'est-à-dire de donner
corps à la nation en demandant à ces
personnes de faire du roman national de
faire de ce que nous sommes leurs
valeurs on en arrive à une situation
telle que celle-ci aujourd'hui il y a
une montée de de la délinquance qui est
bien entendu en partie liée à
l'immigration alors nous verrons ce qui
sera en détail dans cette affaire mais
ce qui est certain c'est que les profils
que l'on voit les les les témoins qui
ont dit on vient buté du blanc ou je ne
sais plus quels étaient les termes
montre bien
encore
témoignag rép la question àorigine
d'ailleurs elle était savoir encore une
fois s'il y a pas un un délai de
d'essence ne serait-ce que pour attendre
les premières conclusions de de
l'enquête et éviter de commettre des
impères euh en en réagissant trop vite
mais attendez à un moment je vous dis
l'IND des sens c'est de ne pas agir on
peut plus laisser du temps on peut plus
laisser le temps aux bougies à au fait
de de faire des tweet aller poser une
rose et cetera ça c'est le rôle des
citoyens et ils ont raison ça nous a
tous touché c'est l'émotion ça pourrait
être mon cousin ça pourrait être mon
frère ça pourrait être vos enfants nos
enfants mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'à un moment ce qu'on attend des
personnalités politique quand on vit
dans dans un tel climat après des
émeutes il y a quelques mois après des
après l'attentat d'aras c'est qu'on
agisse donc à un moment bien entendu on
a témoigné notre émotion mais notre rôle
en tant que personnalité politique en
tant qu'oosant à au gouvernement qui
n'agit pas en la matière c'est dire que
l'IND desens c'est celle de Madame borne
c'est celle de Monsieur darmadin qui ne
font strictement rien les drames
continuent le sang coule dans notre pays
et rien n'est fait Julien parle de la
migration oui alors le texte sorti du du
Sénat a été fortement durci par la
majorité sénatoriale vous l'avez
constaté est-ce qu'il vous satisfait en
état bah ce qui est certain c'est que
tout ce qui va vers plus de fermeté peut
obtenir notre assentiment notre soutien
et donc bien entendu tous les articles
supplémentaires notamment tous les
articles additionnels tout ce qui est
des dispositions qui vont aller vers
plus de fermeté nous pourrons soutenir
ce qui vous allez le voter ou pas parce
que ce qu'on comprend pas très bien
c'est qu'à un moment Marine Le Pen elle
disait qu'elle pourrait voter le texte
même si c'était une petite loi mais a
parl du texte d'armanin là le texte il a
été considérablement durci par le Sénat
et maintenant dit qu' le le moment où on
a dit qu'on le voterait c'est quand il y
avait le texte de Monsieur Darmanin sans
l'article 3 où il y avait la rumeur
qu'il y avait des négociation de
RET il y avait la rumeur et la question
qui avait été posée à Marine Le Pen
c'était sans l'article 3 c'est-à-dire la
régularisation des personnes sans papier
qui travaillent sur des métiers en
tenstion elle avait dit si il n'y a plus
l'article 3 nous pourrons le voter de la
même manière oui et vous le savez très
bien il y a l'article 4 bis qui est une
réécriture de l'article 3 qui donne la
possibilité dans le cadre de la
circulaire Vals au préfet la capacité de
régulariser les préfets c'est une rouge
c'est une min rouge nous nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui quand euh 7
Français sur 10 attendre plus de fermeté
sur l'immigration attendre une politique
de de fermeté en la matière on ne peut
pas créer une nouvelle manière de de
venir en France un nouvel appel d'air et
surtout et c'est pas moi ça durcit ce
qui existe
déjàénager pourquoi vous votez pas c'est
un truc non non ça pérénise attendez ça
pérénise et ça met dans la loi la
circulaire Val c'est-à-dire ça pérénise
et ça met dans la loi quelque chose qui
permet au Préfet de régulariser des
travailleurs sans papier donc on crée
une nouvelle filière d'immigration alors
plus automatiquement mais dans tous les
cas le préfet répondant aux ordres quand
même de l'exécutif on se doute bien que
quand un gouvernement tel que celui que
nous avons aujourd'hui avait dit qu'il
voulait le faire de manière automatique
on se doute bien que le préfet va le
faire de manière assez large et va
régulariser un certain nombre de
personnes qui n'ont pas arrêle au au
mieux de quelques milliers de personnes
ça vous en sa rien c'estd vous c'est les
études qui le qui le disent c'est c'est
étudié par le ministère de l'intérieur
par le gouvernement à un moment on ouvre
une nouvelle porte on donne un nouvel
outil que l'on met dans la loi et ça ce
n'est pas possible je pense que les
Français attendent autre chose et
surtout ça a été dit moi ce qui me gêne
que ça soit dans l'article 3 ou dans la
nouvelle version de l'article 3 le 4 bis
réécrit par le Sénat avec avec l'accord
des des républicains c'est le fait qu'on
fait une prime à la clandestinité c'estd
des personnes qui sont rentrées
illégalement qui travaillent
illégalement vont obtenir des papiers et
ce n'est pas moi seul qui le dit c'est
même un certain nombre de personnes
importantes de la majorité notamment
neimamchou vice-président de l'Assemblée
nationale horizon membre de la majorité
qui a dit que c'était une prime à la
clandestinité voilà ce qui nous gêne et
voilà ce qui est la ligne rouge mais
c'est le cas aujourd'hui oui et est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres articles quand même
qui pourraient faire l'objet d'un d'un
vote en un vote favorable de la part du
du RN mais je vous dis je pense que
l'essentiel des autres articles sont des
articles qui vont vers plus de fermeté
donc ça ça combien donc ça nous allons
vous voter vous savez comment se fait se
fabrique la loi nous allons voter
sûrement pour un certain nombre
d'articles nous allons déposer des
amendements pour aller plus loin
notamment en matière de droit du sol en
matière de suppression des allocations
pour le réserver uniquement au aux
Français en matière de du fait de
traiter de fait de traiter les demandes
d'asile depuis l'étranger il y il y a
des choses qui vont être aussi portées
par le rassemblement national mais tout
ce qui va aller dans le bon sens vous
savez on a une vision qui est pas
sectaire on va appuyer tout ce qui va
dans le sens de l'intérêt des Français
une dernière question Julien oui parce
que les les républicains brandissent
toujours la menace d'une motion de
censure he si le le 493 était utilisé
pour pour passer cette ce projet de loi
immigration est-ce que vous le vous la
soutiendriez vraisemblablement on est en
capacité parfois avec difficulté puisque
c'est porté par la France insoumise
notamment avec les propos qu'on a pu
avoir sur le Hamas il y a quelques
semaines mais de le faire parce qu'on
pense à l'intérêt général nous
considérons que ce gouvernement doit
être censuré que Madame borne doit
partir et donc nous verrons quels seront
les terme de cette motion de censure
mais s'ils sont acceptables bien entendu
nous voterons une motion de censure
parce que nous n'en pouvons plus de ce
gouvernement estce que je pense que
comme une grande partie des Français
aujourd'hui merci Tom ménager merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité Julien
regarde une de la voie du Nord après les
inondations consacré justement à une
question des questions importantes avec
un expert en assurance qui répond aux
questions de vos lecteur merci beaucoup
Julien merci Thas ménager on passe au
club des territoires